So we got one question that we wanna ask you today.
Okay, well... what's that question?
The question is: If you could change one thing about your body, what would it be?
Only one?
I would change my forehead.
I have a really big forehead.
I'd like to be taller.
The puffiness of my face.
My ears.
I have big ears.
Stretch marks after having a baby.
Can you sit on the chair?
No.
Alright, I want to ask you one question.
What's the question?
If you could change one thing about your body, what would you change?
You know, have a mermaid tail.
Probably like a shark mouth so I could eat a lot of stuff.
If I could have teleportation in my body.
Extra pointy ears.
I want legs like a cheetah so I can run faster like a cheetah.
I could have wings so I can fly.
I don't think there's anything to change.
I like my body actually.
Yeah, you wouldn't change anything?
Nothing else.
Just a mermaid tail.